so what we have here is a solution of
copper sulfate copper sulfate and copper
sulfate is an ionic compound the copper
loses two electrons to the sulfate so
the copper has a positive two charge and
the sulfate has a negative two charge
this becomes this isn't a cation and
this is an anion so you can imagine it's
very easy to dissolve it in a polar
solvent like water so this is an aqueous
solution we are dissolving it in water
and actually does have this blue color
so one way to think about it is this is
a bunch of copper cations dissolved in
water and a bunch of sulfate a bunch of
sulfate anions also dissolved in this
water right over here now we're going to
do a little bit of an experiment we're
going to take some solid zinc solid zinc
would have this kind of metallic gray
color we're going to take a powder of
solid zinc metal and throw it into this
solution and think about what is going
to happen so that's solid zinc right
over there so saw zinc in the solid
state plus this inside of this solution
of copper sulfate what do we think is
going to happen and I actually encourage
you to pause the video look at this
table of electronegativities and look at
what's going on here think about who has
the electrons and who might want the
electrons and then think about what's
going to what you think is going to
happen well let's look at let's look at
the electronegativities right over here
copper is more electronegative more
electronegative than zinc is and so if
there was a way for copper to take
electrons from the zinc it would
especially this copper right over here
these these are positively charged
coppers they would love nothing more
than to take some electrons and become
neutral and look there's someone to take
those electrons from and so what you get
what you get is a redox reaction and
we'll look at the half reactions in a
second you get a redox reaction where
the copper takes the copper takes
electrons from the zinc so be
solid copper neutral solid copper and
the zinc loses those electrons to the
copper and so those become zinc cations
or you could think of it as zinc sulfate
zinc sulfate dissolved in the aqueous
solution so let me write that down
zinc sulfate and that has a negative
charge still and it is an in an aqueous
solution so what will this actually look
like so let me put another glass here so
this is before the reaction starts after
the reaction it's going to look
something like this
zinc sulfate is actually a clearish
looking liquid so let me draw that the
liquid will actually become clear so
zinc sulfate is a clearish liquid
instead of having solid zinc here now
you're going to have solid copper now
you're going to have solid copper that
will have precipitated precipitated out
of the solution so that's pretty neat
and just so we just to make sure that we
understand it in terms of oxidation and
reduction let's think about the half
reactions here let's think about the
half reactions so let's think about the
half reaction the half reaction for zinc
so zinc zinc here zinc here solid zinc
right over here it has a neutral
oxidation state it has no charge and
then we end up we end up right over here
with zinc that has a positive charge a
positive two charge so you get two zinc
with a positive two charge so what
happened right over here it lost
electrons it got oxidized so it lost it
lost two electrons the zinc got oxidized
zinc oxidized the zinc got oxidized and
then what happened to the copper well
the copper started as a cation so it
started in the aqueous solution and then
it gained two electrons it gained two
electrons each atom or each ion of
copper gained two electrons
and then we end up with copper we end up
with copper in the neutral copper in the
solid state so its oxidation number was
reduced it became more negative so we
could say that the copper was reduced
copper reduced by the zinc the zinc
oxidized by the copper and we see that
the sulfate its charge didn't change and
when you're dealing with an actual ionic
compound the oxidation state is its
actual charge it's not hypothetical
anymore